what's going on guys this is rob and
marvel battle lines hit me up and asked
me to tell you guys about marvel battle
lines now this game is an innovative
approach to the card battles genre
through its dynamic 3x4 board that
players will compete on through
single-player missions and player versus
player matches now the general idea is
that by placing and forming a line with
your Marvel characters on this board
they'll activate a battle line which
will deal attack damage to your opponent
and when your opponent's life which is
zero then you basically win now the game
itself launches with over 200 unique
cards you can collect and build decks of
different superheroes and super villains
and the favorites are all there Iron Man
like Panther venom and Squirrel Girl
just to name a few and the game features
an expansive roster of characters that
true Marvel enthusiasts would recognize
like Deathlok Man Thing and grin pool so
make sure you guys check the link down
in the description where you can
download the game on the App Store for
the iPhone and iPad and in the Google
store for Android devices and make sure
you guys check to the end of the video
for more information about it ok
so one of the things that we had talked
about in Charles Souls daredevil is that
Charles Soule never like he never does
self-contained stories right like did
you know Charles Soule is never like
here's one story that's an adventure
with daredevil then here's another story
that's totally unrelated and there's an
adventure with daredevil like he never
does that here's like here's one story
and then a second story and then a third
story and all of them are related and
it's actually really cool to see that
because what it does is it gives new
readers the ability to just kind of jump
on with a new trait with a new story and
while there is a little bit of catching
up to do the story usually keeps them
you know up-to-date with what's going on
a lot of writers are really really good
with that some are bad with that because
that's never their intention to do that
Hickman is a guy who's just like if you
want to read my story you better start
from the beginning that's really how it
goes you know like like Geoff Johns
Green Lantern's like that like you don't
jump into Geoff Johns Green Lantern with
like blackest night like you read Green
Lantern rebirth or you read the last
will and testament of how Jordan bin you
read Green Lantern rebirth and then you
just read ten years worth of comics
that's pretty much how that goes some
writers ignore continuity and it's
entirely different writers write
different ways but this is why I love
Charles Soule because with him writing
daredevil what we do here is we
basically pick up with the return of
Elektra now Elektra showing up at
all-new all-different marvel it was
gonna be daredevil there's no reason it
wasn't going to be even if
was it like the whole daredevil Netflix
series you know Matt Murdock an
electrical hand in hand I mean they're
they're like the one-two punch of good
guys and villains in the realm of
street-level heroes in Marvel Comics a
good spider-man is kind of the exception
of that but it's really really cool to
just sort of see the Sun folks what we
do is we joined your daredevil at 2:30
at two o'clock in the morning and of
course he's immediately being assaulted
by Elektra and this is a cool thing is
because Charles so doesn't leave it
ambiguous is not like Elektra who is she
like issue someone who's dangerous like
is she like a legitimate threat
electricity like she's dangerous as hell
there's no no other way to put it she is
one of the most capable people when it
comes to you know being an assassin when
it comes to attacking people when it
comes to overall ability to inflict
death and destruction she's one of the
top people that you go to the funny
thing about this though is you basically
switch back to 9:00 p.m. earlier in the
day and what we do is we join Matt
Murdock in the middle of a courtroom now
with Matt Murdock being here this is
just Matt Murdock doing Matt Murdock
courts stuff you know he's just a lawyer
it's not the most exciting thing in the
world and it doesn't it's not it doesn't
need to be the reason why is because
this does not focus on that Murdock in
the courtroom this focuses on that
Murdock being aware of the fact that
Elektra is here now Elektra arriving
back in Hell's Kitchen could mean any
number of things and Matt Murdock
recognizes this right I mean he's just
like he's like well God dutiful lecture
is here that it means what one it means
somebody's gonna die it's like that's
just that's just how she rolls like a
lecture does not go into a town and
leave without killing someone maybe
because she wants to maybe it's a
contract whatever the case may be he's
like she's here because she needs
something in addition to this we also
jumped 2 to 10 p.m. which of course is
following the whole the whole situation
of the courtroom with met with Elektra
saying like Matt let's go have a
conversation basically you know her
saying let's go have a sit-down the cool
thing about this is that Charles Soule
kind of give us a refresher right I mean
you know for people that were just
getting into daredevil that were just
picking up with all-new all-different
marvel it's not this great big huge
grandiose origin story and it doesn't
need to be
it's just Charles Soule saying hey guys
there was a point where Elektra was
basically just the college student yo
she was a college student she was a
daughter of a wealthy man who also had
you know criminal ties this led to her
father eventually being killed electro
swore of a debt of vengeance you know
joined the cast of stick you know
eventually took over leadership of the
hand but she was also you know always
fighting daredevil because there she was
showing up in Hell's Kitchen
basically enacting her revenge with
daredevil being a superhero and so
because of this you know there were
instances where daredevil was fully
to look the other way just because of
the fact that there was no stopping
Electra when she set her mind to a
mission but more often than not he would
jump in her way and try to stop her from
getting a revenge just because of the
fact that she was essentially a bad guy
but following this you know it's
basically her sitting down with him
and the two of them kind of you know I
guess you know Charles Soule sitting
down reminding us that Matt Murdock had
done something to wipe the world's minds
of the fact that Matt Murdock and
daredevil are the same person
and that Elektra has been impacted by
this and so Elektra does not know that
Matt Murdock is daredevil instead she
sees them as two distinctly different
people now what she also says is if you
still are in contact with daredevil then
I need to be able to get in tongue our
contact with him I need to meet with him
I have some questions now of course what
Matt Murdock says is okay look I'll
arrange a sit-down which brings us up to
this whole conflict when they're
fighting in the first place because
where Elektra had led Matt Murdock to
believe that this was going to be a
discussion between a couple people that
she had a couple questions she needed
answers instead as soon as he shows up
she's like what did you do with my
daughter what did you do with my child
you know and immediately tries to you
know really tries to beat the
ever-loving tar out of him but this is
where Charles Soule kind of messes with
us a little bit right because we would
look at this and we would say oh god
here comes another retcon that Elektra
had a daughter so on and so forth and
it's kind of cool to mess with this
whole thing because it's interesting to
imagine what the world would be like if
Elektra actually did have a daughter but
in the middle of all this where were
daredevil tries to sit her down you know
in tries to say hey look you have to
calm down he basically appeals to
Electra's knowledge of daredevil himself
keep in mind again Elektra doesn't know
that Matt Murdock is daredevil but she's
fought daredevil a multitude of
different times and for the most part
whenever they fought Daredevils never
given up I mean he would fight her to
the bitter end
even if it meant to do it cost his life
in the process and so more often than
not it's the love that Elektra has for
Matt Murdock back when she knew that he
was daredevil that would cause her to
basically you know drop her weapons and
more or less walk away and say fine I'll
let you go this time and it was always
I'll let you go this time I'll let you
walk away this time I'll let you live
this thought it was always that same way
which is one of the reasons why a lot of
fans started to get burned out of the
whole Elektra dichotomy with with
daredevil but the fact remains here that
what trauma soul does is he has Elektra
explain the entire situation an Elektra
explains it she basically has a daughter
named Iona that her daughter you know
basically just came by way of her having
a kid somewhere along the line you know
becoming pregnant she doesn't really
spill the beans but the indication
here is that it's the child of Matt
Murdock the result is that where Elektra
had sought her revenge after her
father's death when she had trained
alongside stick when she had basically
taken over her role in the hand you know
throughout all this stuff you know when
she was training as a student a stick
that her pregnancy was constantly
something that was getting in the way to
a degree to the point that she basically
left her child and her instructor child
off with a family let the child be
adopted and essentially walked away she
would get updates periodically
but the child was never part of her life
and it was interesting because what
happens is she hands a phone over to
daredevil and says this is the
information this is the evidence that I
have that you did something with my
daughter so what she says is take this
phone do what you need to do but I want
answers and if I don't get answers
anytime soon I'm gonna kill you and so
it's really kind of like a race against
the clock it's what we do as we pick up
that morning at 9:00 a.m. we have
daredevil meeting with foggy Nelson and
again the relationship between the two
of them is very tenuous where they were
strong friends at one point now of
course as we explained in in our first
video on all-new all-different daredevil
their friendships nothing like it used
to be you know foggy doesn't really
trust Matt Murdock the same way he did
but this is kind of the nature of who
they are in terms of how they function
towards individuals in all-new
all-different marvel that is this idea
that Charles Soule is messing with are
they gonna stay friends are they gonna
go their own separate ways it's foggy
Nelson you're gonna walk away from Matt
Murdock you know it's kind of this
ongoing situation of what it is we're
gonna end up seeing
but what foggy does is he tells
daredevil look there's nothing to see
here there's nothing on this phone like
there's I don't know what it is that she
saw I don't know what it is if she told
you she saw but she didn't see anything
there's absolutely nothing here and so
because of this what we do is we follow
daredevil well the questions are being
asked like what's going on you know why
is it that Elektra is so convinced she
has a daughter that she has evidence
that I had something to do with the
vanishing of her daughter when there's
no evidence here now of course Matt
Murdock goes back and brings us
information to Elektra and he recognizes
how dangerous this is because it is
right I mean it's wildly dangerous
electric genuinely believes she has a
daughter and she genuinely believes her
daughter's missing
daredevil walking in and saying hey look
like I hate to be the one to break this
to you but there's no evidence on this
phone that you have a daughter there's
no evidence she even exists and there's
no evidence that I had anything to do
with it he's prodding the beast he's
walking up on a bear just poking it with
a stick because Elektra is just like so
you're telling me that the only evidence
that I had of you having something to do
with my daughter vanishing has
disappeared off the phone that I gave
and so in lectures you know from
Daredevils perspective he's like oh my
god she's gonna think that I wiped the
evidence of my involvement with her kids
kidnapping and that's the worst case
situation because in his mind he's like
if she just decides to freak out she'll
probably kill me and that's true that's
the that's the coolest thing about this
is Elektra is so capable of an assassin
that daredevil literally has to sit down
and recognize the fact that if she set
her mind to killing him she would do it
and there'd be almost nothing he can do
to stop her because she's such a capable
assassin as skilled martial arts I mean
you gotta think Elektra was basically
trained by stick that's the same person
that daredevil was trained by she led
the hand she's died she's come back to
life she's had all these different
instances where she's learned fighting
from a multitude of and people trained
all over the world she's about as deadly
as it gets but what happens is she
basically races off to go back and meet
with her contact the person that
basically tipped her off to everything
that was going on in daredevil in the
first place and this is worth a plot
thickens right because what happens is
daredevil shows up in the midst of
Electress conversation with this guy and
this guy in the in the blue coat
somewhat just says the tangled web we
weave and that Elektra seems to go into
a trance seems to just kind of you know
dissolve down into a comatose position
or it basically seems to come to the
realization of what's happening that she
never actually had a daughter instead
she had just been tricked into it now of
course the question is asked is why
what's this guy doing here why in the
heck did he ask this question in the
first place but even daredevil has his
own questions like one who gave her this
phone who was it that set this whole
thing up in the first place why is it
that somebody is going to such great
lengths to basically make it look like
Daredevils a bad guy to essentially take
all of his allies or even those people
who were on-again off-again allies and
turn them against daredevil effectively
turning his life upside down who is it
that's orchestrating all this stuff who
is it that's behind it well of course
with the questions aren't answered by in
this particular volume is it's pretty
short it's only a couple issues but
again it's really just kind of Charles
Soule setting the stage for things to
come telling us that there's there are
much bigger forces at play here though
there's somebody out there sitting in
the shadows that's working against
daredevil by literally turning his life
upside down and turning upside down the
lives of the people that he knows and
those individuals that are close to him
but with that being said guys if you are
new here to count let's explain make
sure you hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob port if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
leave a comment down below let me know
what you guys think about all-new
all-different daredevil I know it's
getting some mixed reactions there are
some that absolutely
love it and there are some who are just
like this is boring SH yeah like it just
depends it depends on where you're
coming from I kind of like it but again
you also have to recognize what that
with Charles Soule he plays a long game
by kind of breaking stories up into
digestible bites but it's always just
like an ongoing thing it's always like a
huge ongoing story you just kind of have
to read from beginning to end now where
this ends we're not sure but the fact
remains here that it seemed like a
pretty good run you know as far as I'm
concerned but yeah guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all later peace marvel battle
lines the game that you can download by
clicking the link in the description
that will take you to the App Store
where you can download it for the iPhone
and the iPad or where you can go to the
Google Play Store and download it for
Android devices this game launches with
over 200 DD cards that you can collect
and build decks from different
superheroes and supervillains the
favorites were pretty much all there I
am an Black Panther venom and Squirrel
Girl just to name a few and the game
features this expansive roster of
characters that true Marvel thews iasts
like myself would recognize such as
Deathlok Man Thing and grin pool now
since this is a Marvel product
the game features gorgeous comic quality
artwork and stunning visual effects and
the marvel battle lines features a
variety of modes including a
single-player campaign with an original
story crafted by Marvel writer Alex
Irvine a special ops mode in challenge
modes and of course a competitive PvP
arena where you can compete against
other players to move up the rankings so
make sure you guys check the link down
in the description and I will see you
all in the next video peace
[Music]